[Laughter]
what's going on reject nation greg and
john here
as you can see i finally got my new rock
star's vision shirt
and of course it's the day after putting
up our one division episode eight
reaction
so we gotta check out eric voss's easter
eggs and break down video before we go
into that gotta give a huge thank you to
today's video sponsor whom i
first heard about from new rockstars and
that is manscaped and if you didn't know
manscape makes the finest men's grooming
products in all the land
especially when you need to shave you
know where your balls
say john your balls your balls
manscaped is making trimming and
grooming easier and safer than ever with
their new and improved
lawnmower 3. this thing has manscaped
skin safe technology to keep you from
goring yourself in the shower while you
reach for those hard to reach
places balls this thing reduces cuts and
nicks and it's waterproof so you can
shave in any weather especially for our
female subs they also offer their crop
preserver ball deodorant
along with a lovely toner mist not to
mention nail clippers they got
ball wipes they got a nose trimmer they
got t-shirts
t-shirts for your balls manscape
literally sent us their whole line of
products
way too much to feature all right here
and i can't show my balls on camera but
if you want to get started we highly
recommend the performance package i've
had the performance package since
2.0 and it's got all the manscaped
essentials it's got
the lawnmower it's got the ball
deodorant and toner they've even thrown
in the weed whacker now for your nose
and ears so that's that's more than i
got when i did it so check out our link
in the description box and use promo
code
reel 20 reel to save 20 on your order
plus free shipping on manscape's
performance package
3.0 let's do this
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of juana
mission episode 8
a trip through history that probably
broke your heart somehow
i'm here for you we're going to go back
through this episode frame by favoriting
all the visual details so far latin you
need translated and the ingredients
thank you
hopeless fan theories that you need
evidence to justify
here we go on so we got to start in a
previously on segment the audio mix
boosts the violent hits of wanda's past
the plot yes
thanos's backhand the prying of the
stone from vision's head
[Music]
just a reminder that wanda's past has
been brutal
she has suffered so much but all this
suffering is so that she can learn a key
lesson about grief that it is actually
love persevering you'll notice the
marvel title card beats two slides
the color of agatha harkness as we open
on this salem witch trial
sort of like agatha's in the comics but
here trial by witches
when your own coven doesn't want you you
know you [ __ ] up leading this heaven
is agatha's mother evanora harkness
wearing the brooch its three figures
resemble the three graces of greek
mythology though given this is a coven
it could reflect the three witches of
macbeth
or the three fates of greek mythology
which does connect with aguila plucking
wanda's hair to represent wanda's
lifeline evanora accused
they simply bent to my power this is
similar to steven strange who learned
sorcery too quickly and fast-tracked
himself to sorcerer's supreme by reading
forbidden hits
book was the dark hold a book many of us
believe is actually from the camartage
library with its hexagonal slots though
that open slide invisible in the doctor
strange movie was not for the dark hold
it was the book of cagliostro which was
yeah there in that shot
i cannot control it roughly translating
to death to the monster of nature so
this means they view her as a freak of
nature that needs to be put down
a natural threat that is beyond which
cultural norms
it's also notable that their spells most
spells found in real world
you know look we're all witches you're
freaking out but you're kind of freaking
out the witches are
you're concerned about your behavior
here's something else there's something
else i can thought i don't know like a
good sacrifice
we all like a good midnight incantation
we all like a good smell
too far all right you're a freak i get
that probably
looked at them and said it's because of
people like you i was afraid to go to
school as a child
muted most spells found in real world
tomes
are in that language and i see this as
tying the mcu's witchcraft to
christian medieval history which means
all that fire and brimstone of christian
dogma
could come with it mag of this purple
mist zack snyder's got to jump in here
man
that's right independent sentience is
protecting her
and so she's able to drain the life
force from the others and notice how
that magic rests in her palms in a mix
of purple and blue
suggesting she has the power of all nine
and these also become the two colors
does not gain when she drains her mother
though in wanda's vision of her future
as a scarlet witch her
tiara does appear on her head this might
tell us what agatha wants from wanda
the crown that is worn by the dominant
oh
dude you saw that earlier
i believe in warrior falls where royals
do fight for that throne which
interestingly
is also passed along via a kind of
purple colored sorcery
leaves us in a trail of purple magic
that dissolves into the purple universe
no i know she does look shocked to meet
the realest so
last week i wondered if senor scratchy
could be nicholas scratch agatha the sun
transmuted into pietro but after this i
am now back to my first
instinct that this rabbit could be
agave's husband ralph we know this
rabbit is important folks
agave says the real us she feeds him an
insect which he gobbles up despite
rabbits being herbivores
he sits right behind me he doesn't want
it cannot look away
from this rabbit in this moment i mean
the rabbit's hitting a freaking bird
that's why
yeah it's a little much to see later she
points out these runes that are
protection spells one has this m
shape but you could see agatha's house
here as a house of
m within an inspired story
wait a minute those look pretty similar
yeah
you know the the i mean they're both
just m's
with different shapes around them
and she explains fake pietro or fiatro
that was you no it wasn't literally me
just my
eyes and yours all right eric tell us
what this is all about
necromancy was a non-starter since your
real brother's body was on another
continent
so earlier this week kevin feige said
evan peters casting was to use his words
just another way that certain people
were messing around with wanda
yeah i'm sure the fox quick silver fans
will accept that it's also interesting
how feige said certain people
another hint that agatha might not be
working alone actually
he did not create the hex but just
rather crash the party that wanda
started i
sensed this place so many spells
cast all at once i couldn't make heads
or tails of it
which begs the question if she could
sense the hex shouldn't
also the sorcerer's supreme doctor
strange be able to sense it
steve wherever he could be on his way
and she controls this
impediment imperio
in latin roughly i have control of the
animal
look latin heads i know it doesn't match
up it's hard to hear exactly what
they're saying and they don't give
subtitles and then she transmutes the
skater into a
bird
which roughly transform your appearance
and then she uses wanda's hair to
project her back into her memories i
gotta say man is putting it in
latin versus english is is so much
cooler because if you just say that [ __ ]
in english
it's just important controlling you yeah
yeah there's like
what dumb exposition lines for the show
don't tell
please
remember literally i think it's just
remember memory and remember doctor
strange similarly plucked one of thor's
hairs out of his head here the hair
extends into this lifeline bisecting
this door with nine
circles which might reflect those nine
nine
nine and seven others they could also
reflect the nine circles of hell in
dante's inferno in which dante and
virgil traverse
and observe each ring of hell the bottom
most layer
is frozen like it is but listen to the
music
at first i was like this is a cool pool
but that's actually pretty good
shallow notes sounds a lot like the
tragic porch theme from the end of
infinity war
moments after wanda lost vision and
dusted into the void
so we find out what the sitcoms are all
about maximoff family love to watch
sitcom dvds instead of oh
i don't know fleeing the country
so what do we got here i love lucy
bewitched adam's family who's the boss i
dream of jeannie malcolm in the middle
well this was in 1999 michael in the
middle of season one didn't come out on
dvd until 2002. oh shut up this is sweet
and i notice what your mom does
hey alternate universe dvd that is the
sakobian greeting that wanda envisioned
brought up jokingly
in episode one that this is the
traditional
sokovian greeting of hospitality
uh guess who oh is that my husband
i would never have picked that up oh my
goodness
that seems very intentional first
episode first memory
that's beautiful and dark and super sad
at the same time
all over again so wanda singles out her
favorite tv episode as the dick van dyke
show season two episodes
are correct look like a walnut now
technically that's the 20th episode yeah
that season reorders it to number 21 but
this isn't just any episode folks
in this episode rob watches a scary
sci-fi tv
program about aliens and glowing walnuts
about people losing their thumbs
because the aliens don't want humans to
be able to make technology that can
threaten them
and then he wakes up in a twilight zone
scenario in which this seems to have
come
true this is exactly what westview is
for wanda it is a classic sitcom that
also has elements of the twilight zone
that seems to be weirdly obsessed with
flying saucers and aliens and with
hayward seems to be connected to a plot
about playing god with tech had a
paranoia of alien threats and meanwhile
their descriptions of this genre
one episode inspired
all this dick van dyke's one episode
dick van dyke created the hex
hey man that's i've seen some pretty
wild theories about dick van dyke's
gonna show up i would love dick man
to be the big character comes out tap
dancing
for it let's do it connected to a plot
about playing god with tech
at a paranoia of alien threats and
meanwhile their descriptions of this
genre match the genre bending aspect of
wand division itself along with where
this show might be going
again is a problem but more silly than
scary but can sometimes be a little
scary
a silly mischief that always becomes
fine by the end of the episode
you realize it was all a bad dream but
then
boom you're looking for this the home
gets bombed and then we see that stark
industries bombshell feet away the story
they told in age of ultron and of course
it beeps
effect and blinking as that stark
toaster in the commercial
those are not the parents no
but interestingly this bomb failed to
detonate not by chance but rather wanda
using a probability hex
chaos magic powers in the comics and a
major detail confirming that juan's
powers did not come fully from the mind
stone but existed
in a lower powered form from birth
meaning this is in her dna
she's got a mutant gene folks but then
notice behind the bomb big fan
it's so true because man we're not even
like halfway through
that's uh i mean people were pointing
out in the comments of our last video
uh something we didn't address because i
was like oh it's cool she's you know i
got the magic powers in the beginning
but i didn't even think about how
mutant dna usually occurs around the age
of 10 if i'm not mistaken some 10 to
teenage years actually says 10. since
she's 10.
she's 10 in this flashback according to
what they said an age of ultron yeah
that would be a great mutant
tie-in without having to say it but
obviously setting the groundwork for it
absolutely but peters was setting the
groundwork for it but now this is she's
got a mutant gene folks
van dyke says on the tv
and i am legally obligated to point out
every mention of the word nightmare just
because nightmare is
being in this then to the hydra lab
where one tells
everyone we wanted to change the world
it started as a political ideal but
wanda is now capable of doing this
literally and then i
love this transition the camera pulls
back into the chamber but uh just
kidding we're actually seeing a mirror
surface but no
camera reflected in that mirror i keep
mentioning references to contact in
these breakdowns but this impossible
mirror shot is also a famous maneuver
from that movie it's one of my favorite
shots
ever in movies and in that sense great
holy [ __ ] just like this is for wanda
now this
mind stone oddly seems to select wanda
it washes yellow radiation over her
and her eyes reflect the silhouette of
her future form
or maybe an alternate reality form
either way
a true nexus being the scarlet witch
this actually could be the figure we saw
briefly in wanda's eyes at the end of
episode six
the moment she expanded and for the
first time threatened this universe with
a house of m style rewrite
and then when they tried to play back
the video glitches from right before to
right after
just like the editing glitches later in
western [ __ ] her first experience
everything's
but this also happens at the movie
contest and all this external video
skips over
ellie's trans-dimensional trip seriously
is that damn cameo going to be jody
foster wanda watches an episode of the
brady bunch with
cindy brady's doll this is the same doll
vision practice diaper changing honestly
oh yes
music
moving on up so where are we now
i just got stopped because i mean that
is so crazy to know like even
some of these gags these bits that were
in the first few episodes when audiences
were like where's this show really going
are we just going to stay in sitcom land
forever
to find out not only is it just imbued
with the dna of her character of like oh
she
grew up watching sitcoms it was her
escapism but even these little details
like the sokovia greeting
like the doll that i'm sure maybe
there's even more to come in this
breakdown but
that's just so neat that they were more
than just funny little gags they were
actual
connect tie-ins to specific memories
yeah the more we see these the more it
seems like nothing is incidental
yeah avengers compound yeah that music
is a dark version of the classic
avengers theme this is set around the
time of civil war when she was under
lockdown and getting to know vision
making some pepper cash together she
watches an episode of malcolm in the
middle where the roof collapses on brian
cranston maybe reflecting how wanda's
hex begins to collapse as the decades
progress
into that era and then vision gives us
the amazing line really the reason these
two weirdos are able to fall in love
but what is grief if not love
persevering
wanda isn't looking at her i think i get
connected to that
she is so desperate come on wanda you're
on the precipice
you are right there who wouldn't connect
tell me how you did it
vision was gone but you
wanted him back i wanted it back
and notice agatha's face as god i hope
she gets his name
is going to do something i believe again
someone she loved and that is why she
was so genuinely emotional when she
heard wanda could raise the dead
you can do that so at sword hq looks in
it
through the monitor just like she did
via the drone camera in episode 5.
behind the desk is a star map front and
center is gemini
the twins like juana pietro billy and
tommy and notice how hayward calls
vision
the vision which is also how it's listed
on the deed nice to see the mcu
use the the like in the comments and
then hayward shows wanda visions parts
bit hard to watch the wiring pulls apart
with a slick
sound as if it was sinew and muscle
tissue
and then under that skin it looks like
some hexagonal tissue there
so why did hayward wait to dismantle
vision until now
the vision has been dead for years did
he fear that they'll return to [ __ ]
that's got to say i got this shirt and i
paid for a custom
text that's supposed to say something
about hexagons
i wrote it in myself boss boss fix this
this is i know you're running the epic
did he fear that the returned avengers
would try to seize the parts
did wakanda not release the body until
shuri and t'challa
blipped back well take a step back and
look at this scene the sword techs are
sloppy
yanking vision apart like an old car
weapon and this looks like tim the tool
man taylor's garage
excuse me not everyone has the kind of
power that could bring their soulmate
back online
forgive me back to life and throughout
this he is watching wanda closely with a
bit of hopefulness
and he tells his men to stand down yeah
clearly this is all a show by hayward
he once wanted to take this corpse over
the past years he has been trying to
reboot vision thousands of times
to no avail and now that wanna
maximoff's back he
is butchering vision trying to incite
wanda into snatching the body and using
her sorcery hayward hopes to bring this
back online
and when wanda leaves without visions
corpse he's disappointed he lies to
monica saying that one it did
while throwing monica at west view
hoping for a
sample of wanda's magic which okay but i
don't know if
it's something that we can we'll know
now maybe we'll find out in the next
episode
this can't have been his plan from day
one i completely agree that that's
everything he wanted to do has brought
in our reaction but did he just
improvise
this on the spot when she showed up
that's why there was such a delay with
letting her in the room like he must
have
made this kind of impromptu decision to
let her test this out
to see if maybe she's here maybe she
could bring him back or did he always
want to bait her
into coming by i gotta imagine that you
know he's had that speech about like you
know we were here well unless you guys
got snapped away and whatever
so i would imagine that maybe he figured
that once the blip happened
like okay i've got another option back
on the table or something like that with
wanda yeah because it's kind of
interesting that he would wait they've
had vision's body for years so they
could have been disassembling it for
quite a long time
yeah so did they decide to just only
recently start to disassembly
in hopes of luring wanda back or have
they just been trying to get this
working for
forever because it seems like pretty new
that they just started doing this the
disassembly
yeah like it just started yeah i i
wonder if maybe
that is due to knowing wanda's out there
and whatever
yeah but uh i have to imagine he's been
working for years on at least trying to
get vision
throwing monica at west view hoping for
a sample of wanda's magic which he gets
eventually with that stark drone getting
the fuel for his project cataract to
reboot vision giving us
white vision in the post-credits scene
wow one position is from the vision
quest comics and the west coast avengers
series in the 80s where the avengers are
trying to reassemble vision's body
the visuals of him on the different
tables actually looks very similar but
because
vision does not have the same brain
waves that he used to have he comes back
in this soulless white form
in the comics there's a lot of other
characters involved with this from the
grim reaper to wonder man to hank pym to
even the human torch
and technically a mortis who is the same
person as kang the conqueror
seems like one division might not bring
in any of them hayward is the government
who wants superheroes he can control as
weapons and the fact that white vision
has a
stark-esque park reactor
echoes the way tony stark tried to do
this which
led to the folly of ultron and the
saving grace of the true vision
this plan is why hayward here ultimately
just puts a price tag on vision
i cannot allow you to take three billion
dollars worth of vibranium just to put
in the ground
see what i'm thinking is that the white
vision thing is more
in tribute to white vision i don't feel
like they're going to be adapting the
storyline from it
like let's aesthetically make him look
like it have some of that
after being reassembled type of dealio
yeah i completely get i think that's all
in tribute to white vision but i don't
think
they're going to be going that path i
think they're going to have him be a
little bit more
sentient weapon vision yeah more
straight to the action
less anything intellectual but i could
be wrong i could be wrong that's just
kind of the hunch i'm getting
like you that way you really distinguish
between the vision that wanda's created
and then the ultimate evil plan or not
evil plan but plan that hayward had that
is really messed up
that will completely go wrong you know
that like that plan just has to go wrong
and then you mesh them together right
hopefully wanda's vision can just go
into
all that mine stone juju can go into
white vision brings
color back to put it in the ground if
you think about it that is exactly where
the vibranium belongs the vibranium
that made vision was stolen from the
soil of wakanda meanwhile wanda's plan
it seems like was to try to bury vision
in that plot he bought for them in west
view new jersey
when did he get that deed he must have
done it before they went on the run
after civil war in 2016. he is
essentially a guy who got an engagement
ring after the first date in other words
a creep
and then wanda says here okay which of
course is a callback to infinity war
when one used her magic in the earlier
scene to sense vision's soul from that
mind stone
and these were also his final words to
her before she destroyed that stone at
the end of the movie and heading to west
view wanda drives a
red car it's got a license plate reading
excelsior which of course is just the
new york state motto
all these plates but also it is stan
lee's headlights we see john collins aka
herb
sharon davis aka mrs hart dennis the
mailman aka
i love this edition i love this editing
pizza pizzas
he puts the map for piano lessons
remember he played it at the talent show
until it was flattened
that was my grandmother's piano on the
deed vision's note is outlined
like the date on the calendar in episode
one the heart they could not remember
the meaning of oh
oh [ __ ] i didn't even realize that's the
producer of the brady bunch and a bunch
of other sitcoms
and it is signed off by the name kate
weddle who is an assistant art director
on one division and in her grief wanda
uses her sorcery to
construct this dream home the house
builds oh wait we gotta pause that the
whole thing with the heart yeah because
i remember that being i said
i haven't won before we watched any of
the one division episodes i remember
that being part of like yeah
what's this all about what does the
heart mean it was like oh just a
confusion a date again
seeming like it's just another gag uh
setting up a traditional sitcom
plot i didn't even piece that together
that it's so heartbreaking
like right in the center of the calendar
it's right in the center of the deed
that is
devastating heartbreaking you're late
john i said it i was waiting i
didn't even listen to anything you were
saying after i said the words
heartbreaking
punchline john punchline you're supposed
to go off and then you just started
talking yeah you're four people
yeah too late too late comedy is all
about
time house built in jigsaw chunks
interestingly evoking the puzzle pieces
and this hex spreads like a wave a
reversal of wanda's admission earlier to
feeling like she was caught in the wave
getting toppled over and over
now she is a seismic event that spreads
the weight outward the west view dairy
billboard reverts from the red carton
you know what it kind of reflects too
when quicksilver died in
an age of ultron and she had the
breakdown falling moment
someone told me that over the phone
yesterday
[Laughter]
secret easter egg from above thick event
that spreads the weight outward
the west view dairy billboard reverts
from the red carton modern one to the
old timey bottles just like wanda's
glitching milk last episode and then
over on the right a new ad for
lagos paper towels make cleaning up a
snap
like you know the the snap that thanos
did the movie theater marquee changes
from 10 hour gate
a nod to blade runner that was the warp
station referenced in the amazing tears
of rain monologue
now it reads big red and kidnapped the
way these town residents are essentially
kidnapped
inside the house wanda recreates vision
solely out of yellow magic due to her
magic being amplified by the yellow mine
stone
and in the tv reflections you can see
vision's mindstone is the last part of
him to form
this means that the vision in westfield
is resurrected purely from wanda's magic
and has no corporeal counterpart yet he
is still real
inside the hex because remember hayward
was able to track his vibranium decay
as a nexus being wanda isn't just
creating illusions
she's creating real tangible alternate
realities
and then in the tv studio behind the
stage lights is the year 2013
which does anchor this final modern
family sitcom year as the year 2013 even
though on the outside world it is 2023
and then outside final scene agatha
restrains billy and tommy on these
choke leashes you have no idea
how dangerous you are you're supposed to
be a myth
of being capable of spontaneous creation
here you are using it to make breakfast
for dinner it's called mackwanda
improvising breakfast for dinner but now
looking back on it those complex recipes
provided by agnes might have actually
been spells from the darkhold
that agatha was using to test
so one and following the basics like she
had to wanda could just skip that
textbook
and agave ends with this is chaos magic
wanda
and that makes you the scarlet [ __ ]
this is the first for two terms in the
mcu chaos magic which is of course the
type of magic wanda uses in the comics
the reason she can chaotically rewrite
the universe as a nexus bean and then of
course her basic superhero name scarlet
witch never been said before in the mcu
and now it's in this interesting context
as being elevated as a kind of royal
title that agatha seeks but why does
agatha want it what does agatha want
well again akavith seems to have lost
someone she loves and she's frustrated
that she can only do basic spells like
animal transmutation while wanda just
has this innate
power 400 years later
folks read up on your history it's not
reaching to assume
this witch would claim her spouse to be
the devil
yeah folks i'm going down with the ship
don't do it argument agatha's husband
ralph is mephisto
scratchy the rabbit a reference to old
scratch a nickname for the devil this
rabbit is the best agatha could do
i stand
he's got real star quality don't you
think it was his
demonic protection that allowed agatha
to overthrow the coven
broke his soul because agatha was not
the scarlet witch that he
thought she was she did not get the
crown and as in the west coast avengers
comics
this series is now definitely based on
evidence by white vision
soul is broken in those comics agatha
helps him manipulate wanda using pieces
of his soul
to create billy and tommy they are shown
to be hand puppets of
mephisto's minion and now agatha puppets
these boys
these illusions are actually draining
some of her life force
these kids were just called demon spawn
and that was not long after
the details bev that's not the only
thing what does that give
she wants the nexus powers of the
scarlet witch she was unable to get them
from her mother and she wants them now
from wanda so that she
can repair mephisto together they can
rule
the multiverse power that the rest of
her covenant thought no one should
harness i know i know it seems like the
betany cameo tease might have been just
him trolling us but
uh i'm gonna place my bets on mephisto
showing up in the finales gonna be
played by an actor so beloved no one's
gonna care that he's been off screen all
season or
charm
china censorship does not actually apply
here we did a whole video on why
we are so close and don't you dare pull
a db cooper on us
hey you can support this channel by
checking out one of our wonderful merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com like
an unusual couple shirt and of course
maybe i'll get it
my vision's brighter than his rockstars
yeah that's
the consolation for not getting
i gotta say man i gotta say
that every time i'm like all right you
know what giving up i guess mephisto
ain't coming back
i guess he ain't coming in you pull
some [ __ ] that just
like oh man he's right maybe oh
well every single time it happens there
and then it's like even
this is even more innate and more
detailed
more tied in than before to the point
where i'm like
oh crap you know there's one more
episode left i think he's got it i think
he's got it
and this got me thinking back now cause
like in that prologue scene of this
episode there is that thing they charge
her with like you know
engaging in some kind of dark ritual is
way
worse than anything they've been up to
and i'm like that's probably gotta be
summoning the devil or making a deal
with him or something
or or a devil of the mcu i believe him i
mean all those
especially at the end there with
everything he was saying you're like oh
crap he's right he's right
i'm mainly hoping for you for you
we don't need this i don't need it i'd
be fine if he doesn't show up dude
you're crying
hope he rides on this he shows up yes
we'll go down
on this ship with you buddy joe pesci
mephisto
all right guys what do you think about
this breakdown please follow new
rockstars
i like i listen and watch their videos
like we usually
mainly cover this weekly one but i
listen and watch their videos all
throughout the week i think you guys
ought to do so yourself especially that
one about sensor
the one that they did there's like a 40
minute podcast that they did about
censorship
that one was like yeah okay no no yeah
you're right
mephisto witches they can all show up
all right guys we'll talk to you soon
thank you for being here
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button
thank you to manscape for sponsoring
this video last but not least gotta
shout out some people who are pledged to
assorted to it
peter pacheco russell beatty giant panda
king abigail
nelson joanna saint louis matthew menser
sandrine little little angel rogue cree
sam castle 9-4 justine martin
kayla waiters rosie beatty darth yoda
2012
ruby dynamite philip junior smith
jr jen smith brianna david's son
milani leblanc brittany baierly
natalie duran let's just became the bit
now
found the business erwin ragiere
marcus where de menon kahasi
gardner tiana eva drazikova
kent mcneet thank you guys so much
for respecting our names and i'm glad we
could respect yours
as well seriously thanks for being part
of our patreon page you guys rock
hopefully you enjoy the random stuff we
post there
much love and your support has uh
carried us through
many tough times thank you guys
much love love see you guys next month
or tomorrow